those who responded to an extremely
distressing event
information is still being gathered
about the situation in france as this
becomes more and more clearer the prime
minister chaired the emergency cobra
meeting last night and then spoke to the
president of france i'm glad that
president macron indicated his
determination to stop the vile people
smuggling gangs and importantly to work
with work closely with all partners
across europe i have literally madame
deputy speaker just spoken again with my
french counterpart minister domin and
i've once again reached out and made my
offer very clear
to france in terms of joint france and
uk cooperation
joint patrols to prevent these dangerous
journeys from taking place i've offered
to work with france to put more officers
on the ground and do absolutely whatever
is necessary to secure the area so that
vulnerable peoples do not risk their
lives by getting into unseaworthy boats
madam deputy speaker there is a global
immigration illegal migration crisis
as i've stated many times
these journeys across the channel are
absolutely unnecessary
but i as also as i have been warning for
two years they are also lethally
dangerous
what happened yesterday was a dreadful
shock it was not a surprise but it is
also a reminder of how vulnerable people
are
put at peril when in the hands of
criminal gangs
there is also madame deputy speaker no
quick fix
this is about addressing long-term pull
factors smashing the criminal gangs that
treat human beings as cargo and tackling
supply chains
this requires a coordinated
international effort and i've been in
constant contact with my counterparts
from france poland austria belgium italy
and greece to name just a few
because of the nature of the crisis and
the fact that we are seeing 80 million
displaced people in the world this was
of course madame deputy speaker a major
theme of discussion at the g7 interior
ministers back in september we're also
seeing it play out on several land
borders in europe and in the
mediterranean sea
and given the chance the traffickers
will always find people to exploit and
manipulate some of them do not even know
that they are coming to the uk
this does mean tackling issues upstream
and not waiting until people have
reached eu countries and i've always
been extremely clear that i want to
cooperate and am cooperating with
international colleagues
the united kingdom has given its
unflinching and generous support to
france to end this terrible trade in
people smuggling
we are not working just to end these
crossings because we don't care and
we're heartless the united kingdom has a
clear and a generous humane approach to
asylum seekers and refugees
yes people should come here legally and
the system must be fair but the main
issue is this crossing the channel in
small boats is extremely dangerous and
yesterday was the moment that many of us
had feared for many years
the criminals that facilitate these
journeys are motivated by self-interest
and profit not by compassion
they threaten intimidate bully and
assault the people who get into these
bows and they have a complete absolute
disregard for human right
they use the money they make for other
heinous crimes and we simply have to
break their business model and of course
bring them to justice the government's
new plan for immigration which will be
put into law
through the nationalism borders bill is
a longer-term solution that will address
many of these underlying factors to
deter illegal migration and addressing
underlying pull factors into the uk's
asylum system
it will bring in a range of measures
including the one-stop appeals process
the ability to process claims outside
the country the ability to declare
inadmissibility to our asylum system and
have differentiation those who arrive in
the uk having passed through safe
countries and lives and life sentences
for people smugglers
people should madam deputy speaker claim
asylum in the first safe country they
reach and nobody needs to be
nobody needs to flee france in order to
be safe
however madden deputy speaker we are not
waiting until the nation borders bill
passes we are undertaking a wide range
of operational and diplomatic work
i have already approved maritime tactics
including boat turnarounds for boarder
force to deploy
the government the police the national
crime agency are taking action at every
level to take down the people smuggling
gangs and once again however we cannot
do it alone
we continue to work closely with the
french prevent crossings more than 20
000 have been stopped this year which i
think all members of this house should
recognize the magnitude and the scale of
the illegal migration crisis that we are
seeing
we have dismantled 17 organized criminal
groups
and secured over 400 arrests and 65
convictions
but this crisis continues clearly
demonstrating we need to do more
together this is a complicated issue and
there is no simple fix it does mean a
herculean effort and it will be
impossible without close cooperation
between all international partners and
agencies
i also urge colleagues to reconsider
their opposition to the national interim
borders bill
because it is an essential element in
finding a long-term solution to what is
madam deputy speaker a long-term problem
that successive governments have faced
over decades
as we mourn those who have died in the
most horrendous of circumstances
i hope that the whole house can come
together
to send a clear message
that crossing the channel in this lethal
way in a small boat is not the way to
come to our country
it is of course unnecessary illegal
and desperately unsafe i commend this
statement to the house
nick thomas simmons
thank you madam deputy speaker i'm
grateful to home secretary for her
statement and for advanced side of it
yesterday's human tragedy in the channel
was the most awful of reminders of the
dangers of crossing the channel and the
people's lives are at risk every day in
these makeshift flimsy small boats
it's a sobering moment for our country
for france and for the international
community
we understand that at least 27 people
have died
some reports that include seven women
and three children
and we do think across the house of
those lost and their loved ones left
behind
we think two of those who've been
rescued and are receiving medical
treatment fighting for their lives
i'd also like to pay tribute to all
those involved in the joint french
british search and rescue operation in
the air and on the sea
people putting themselves in danger to
help others
i also understand that there have been
arrests in france of those suspected of
this vile crime of people smuggling
i appreciate very much the difficulties
and sensitivities when there's an
ongoing legal case particularly in
another jurisdiction
i further appreciate it's at a very
early stage but i would be grateful if
the home secretary could give the house
an update on possible timings for the
legal case and reassure the house that
britain will give all cooperation that
is required by the prosecuting
authorities in france and will that full
cooperation extend not only to this
tragic case but all ongoing prosecutions
where we can make an intelligence
contribution
madam deputy speaker i've raised on a
number of occasions before the
arrangements we have in place with the
french authorities and i would ask if
firstly the home secretary could set out
how many days a week
the full existing surveillance capacity
is currently operating and what will the
home secretary be doing urgently to
increase that surveillance
now i paid tribute to the national crime
agency and our front line law
enforcement officers for the work that
they do and i heard what the home
secretary said in her statement about
law enforcement cooperation
but can she also tell the house what she
will do to deepen that intelligence and
law enforcement cooperation with the
french authorities and indeed other
countries
so the focus isn't only on coastal
patrols important though they are but is
also about disrupting the routes
facilitated often across hundreds and
thousands of miles by vile people
smuggling gangs who have reckless
disregard for human life
can i also press the home secretary on
properly managed safe and legal routes
can i ask specifically about the dub
scheme the dub scheme was closed down
having helped only 480 unaccompanied
children rather than the 3000 it was
expected to help will that scheme be
urgently reinstated
the government has also announced the
afghanistan resettlement scheme and we
took the salute yesterday from our
magnificent armed forces in new palace
yard who together with border force and
our diplomats showed the very best of us
as a country in their actions doing
operation pitting
but the government now needs to send out
how practically it will make good on its
promise to help a total of 20 000 people
we are some months on we need an urgent
update on that then there's the uk
resettlement scheme that was announced
in february of this year and today the
government has released the statistics
on this
it shows that in its first year only 770
people have been helped by that scheme
and taking with the other schemes it's
only 1
171 people who've been helped to the end
of september when the promise
from the home office was to help 5 000
people in its first year what will be
done to make good on that promise what
urgent action will be taken to help
those most in need
the home secretary mentioned the
nationality and borders bill but she
knows the opposition will not support a
bill that breaches the refugee
convention and damages our standing
around the world and indeed the home
secretary has spoken today of a
worldwide migration crisis
can ministers revisit their decision to
cut the international aid budget and
lead on the international stage to help
those fleeing from persecution around
the world
and finally madam deputy speaker can i
say that yesterday's terrible tragedy
must be a moment for change
the time for urgent action to save lives
is now
i'm secretary madam deputy speaker um
i'd like to speak in my remarks madam
deputy speaker by actually echoing some
of the comments that the honorable
gentleman made and in particular that is
a direct reference to
actually our partners our partners our
operational partners who day in day out
do incredible work
that sometimes in this house gets
overlooked too often
so on joint patrols for example and i
know the honourable generational
gentleman has asked about surveillance
capability
we have officers from border force and
uk law enforcement working in
conjunction with the national crime
agency and their french counterparts
every day madam deputy speaker and
actually some of the most appalling
conditions and i would also like to
refer all members honourable and right
humble members who previous statements
i've made in this house
around loss of life people smuggling but
actually some of the wider reforms that
this government is bringing in because i
have specifically mentioned just the
weaponizing of illegal migration the
fact that women and children even babies
are being threatened and weaponized and
being forced into some of these most
appalling unseaworthy vessels officers
in france have also been attacked
physically attacked and injured in many
quarters and our border force patrols
and officers themselves deal with many
harrowing scenes every single day so on
that point i would very much like to
just very much support and commend the
work that our people do um this is
difficult work and actually if i may
just come on to the right humble
gentleman's other points as well
including the fact there is a global
migration crisis and this is not new
this is absolutely not you madam deputy
speaker and even my days in my previous
department in development humanitarian
crises climate crisis they all force
displacement and we have seen many many
moves of people movements of people
through the sahel through libya through
the eastern mediterranean since 2013 14
and 15. and this has all culminated now
in much vast people movements obviously
with the afghanistan crisis and other
points as well
but specifically on surveillance
capability and i will come through go
through many of the points that the
right on the gentleman has made
surveillance capability is stood up
every day dependent fundamentally
on for example weather
whether or not planes can fly drones can
fly and in fact madame deputy speaker on
monday when i came to the house for
questions and the urgent questions i
spoke about how drones are now being
used in france whereas previously they
were not being used in france because
their laws did not allow it and we also
have to recognize madame deputy speaker
our laws differ to my counterparts and
our french counterparts and therefore on
intelligence cooperation their laws are
different to our own laws and also their
prosecution powers to our own
prosecution powers as well so it is
absolutely right that we continue to not
just cooperate cooperation is what we do
day in day out but actually how we
intensify
our work how we share data how we share
intelligence and in fact our own laws
prevent some of that from happening and
we are looking at ways in which we can
bolster that and strengthen that and we
have to think about what that means in
terms of data sharing but also on
prosecutions the prosecutions that have
taken place are very significant they
really are prosecution pathways in
france differ to prosecution pathways in
the united kingdom but also how we share
across different jurisdictions
information about individuals that have
been arrested because of course laws are
different different and differ but also
i should just add madame deputy speaker
there are gangs that aren't just
operating on the continent in northern
france or in belgium or netherlands or
germany there are gangs that operate in
the united kingdom and that is where our
resources are absolutely focused
and targeted and this isn't just about
uk france cooperation and i've never
ever said actually and i do want to put
this on the record once again this is
not just a problem for the united
kingdom and france when you look at
europe from the gateway into italy
greece now poland i spoke to my
counterpart in poland earlier on this
week my counterparts in belgium the
netherlands germany you name it we see
this we see this as a wide scale problem
madam deputy speaker just two other
points if i mail the three other points
on resettlement
resettlement is a fundamental pillar of
the work of this government and the
right honourable gentleman has mentioned
resettlement figures i would just like
to caveat much of this though through
the pandemic he will respect and
understand that travel movements have
been restricted resettlement rights have
been limited because of the pandemic but
we are committed and we are working to
absolutely resettle people in the way in
which we have committed to do so and of
course that links to the afghanistan
resettlement scheme in addition to the
15 000 people madame deputy speaker that
were evacuated under operation pitting
and i've also publicly said that we can
only resettle
once we have the ability and the
infrastructure to create resettlement
pathways so that we don't just bring
people here and let them lead an
inadequate right life they need to
rebuild their lives he also mentions the
honorable gentleman right honourable
gentleman also mentions the dub scheme
i've actually put an offer on the table
not for the first time to the french
government today on a returns agreement
but in particular looking at family
reunion children so this is again an
offer that i have made repeatedly to my
counterpart in france we are determined
over the weekend we're going to be
pursuing further discussions we have to
have viable agreements and viable
agreements have to reflect the type of
crisis that we face on migration and the
type of circumstances that we are now
confronted with
syrian duncan smith
i'm deputy speaker can i just say to my
ronald friend it's quite clear obviously
that this is not going to be ended at a
stroke but the reality is that the even
though we are not any longer part of the
dublin convention the dublin convention
is completely broken
uh and that across europe at the moment
lots of countries are happy as long as
someone isn't staying to see those
migrants travel across their country
into somebody else's
jurisdiction and that has led to the
problem that we face now with those
selecting to come to the uk ending up in
france can she assure us in this house
today that she's putting the greatest
pressure on the french government uh to
allow us
uh to work with them in their
territorial area either by using uh
patrol systems or ships and or members
of the police or armed forces to help
them and support them that they should
do that because it would help them as
much as it would help a friend has ever
hit snail on the head and is absolutely
right about the wider issues across eu
member states and we recognize this as
well i'll be speaking to commissioner
johansen later on today as well not for
the first time i've had previous
discussions with her about this i think
number one there is recognition now
and it's i mean it's it's it's
absolutely tragic and appalling madam
deputy speaker that it takes a tragedy
of this nature for momentum to be
galvanized across other countries as
well on this issue um and it should
never take a crisis of this nature for
action to come together but my right
humble friend has specifically asked me
about putting pressure as far as i see
it not just pressure but direct offers
on the table to france about joint
patrols whether it's territorial seas
terror or territory on territory itself
this has been a constant offer it really
has i have made that offer yes again to
my counterpart in the last hour
martian day
thank you madam deputy speaker this is a
devastating tragedy and our thoughts all
going to those who have lost their lives
together with their friends and their
families
i'm grateful for advanced site of the
statement and i agree that greater
cooperation to tackle the dreadful
criminal people smuggling gangs is
required however this awful event should
also signal a massive shift in approach
to provision of safe legal routes to the
uk not doubling down on criminalizing
those who are the victims if they get
here with up to four years in prison
this government's refugee family reunion
rules are among the most restrictive in
europe the dub scheme was closed and
brexit means that the so-called dublin
family reunion applications are no
longer possible resettlement schemes are
in limbo the borders bill will restrict
family reunion rights even further
meaning more people will feel compelled
to make dangerous journeys to join loved
ones the reality is that offshoring is a
disgrace
will she publish the economic impact
assessment for the bill which presumably
will confirm that it will waste billions
of pounds and not work and instead of
blocking and closing down safe routes we
should be expanding them so my question
is quite simple will she commit today to
ending all discussion of the uk using
dangerous and life-threatening push-back
tactics in the channel the prime
minister said yesterday that all options
were on the table in addressing this
crisis will she confirm that this will
include looking at the one measure which
would make an immediate difference
allowing refugees and asylum seekers to
make their initial application from
outside the uk rather than forcing
people to physically travel here to
begin their applications
speaker i have to say i'm very
disappointed by the honourable
gentleman's tone comments
and his actual inability to understand
the situation as to what is taking place
around global illegal migration issues
and challenges first of all i will
restate to the honourable gentleman if
he thinks that there is a simple
solution there is no simple solution and
if he thinks settlement schemes that
have existed previously are the answer
that is also not the answer and if he is
bothered to read the nationality in
borders bill he will also should also
look at the new plan for immigration and
importantly some of the wider reforms
that are required to our asylum system
so that our asylum system actually
becomes fit for purpose so that it meets
the needs of people that are claiming
asylum that we have a differentiated
approach to stop economic migrants
masquerading as asylum seekers and
elbowing women and children who need
help and support out of the way which is
effectively what is happening right now
so safe and legal routes absolutely and
if he only joined in previous debates or
even in previous statements and
questions and i'm not sure if he was
here on monday in the house he would
have heard me say not just on monday but
in fact when i launched a new plan for
immigration back in february the very
purpose of safe and legal rules is
actually so we create the right kind of
resettlement path for people who are
fleeing persecution and depression in
countries for a range of reasons a whole
host of reasons and the world is
changing and there's a great defensive
stability out there but in doing so that
will create them a legal path to make
their claim from outside of the united
kingdom so they won't have to come here
and then when they do come here they are
literally supported in the right way in
terms of accommodation resettlement so
that they can start their new life in
the united kingdom that is exactly how
safe and legal should work that is why
i'm working with the iom and the and
unhcr and other partners on this and i
think it's such a shame actually um that
once again the snp a party that has
failed to support asylum seekers um in
their own local authorities madam deputy
speaker 31 out of 32 local authorities
have not even
they they may sit there and and yell
shame at me
but 31 out of 32 local authorities
madame deputy speaker do not participate
in the voluntary dispersal scheme for
housing asylum seekers so
there is an inconsistency here if i may
say so in their approach and i'm
absolutely in agreement on the need for
safe and legal rules this government
will do it properly while we recognize
the type of instability and uncertainty
and persecution of an oppression that
people that need need to claim asylum
should become an asylum in our country
are currently not getting and we will
change that
david davis uh thank you madame deputy
speaker i think the whole house knows
that my writingable friend has strained
every sinew since her first day in post
to prevent the sorts of tragedies we saw
in the last 24 hours yeah uh she's also
right my right on friends right to point
to the pan-european nature of this
problem and frontex for example have
quadrupled their expenditure on
surveillance alone in the mediterranean
in the last year and she's quite
accurately pointed to her ongoing
cooperation with the french as central
to this so can she tell the house what
additional measures she's offered the
french in order to crack down on these
evil gangs and cut down this deadly
trade well my right-handed friend
absolutely makes such some very very
important points and
my russian friend also mentions frontex
the role of frontex actually to see how
they have actually accelerated
surveillance but even border patrols um
they are even madame deputy speaker
supporting activity in the mediterranean
in terms of stopping boats entering
territorial waters illegally as well and
i've seen those patrols myself i have
seen them so it's a complete myth and
fallacy to say that we shouldn't look at
all options we are and we will continue
to do so but in terms of measures that
have been offered to france absolutely i
mean i've asked them today for an honest
assessment in terms of their own numbers
on the beaches um whether or not there
are gaps if more officers are needed a
realistic assessment in terms of the
number of migrants that are coming
through from from belgium in particular
and minister dharman specifically
mentions the pressures from that border
and the boats that were the fatalities
with the fatalities yesterday they came
from dunkirk so clearly there are more
flows there but absolutely more police
officers
more intelligence cooperation more on
technology so we have put actually for
we put forward a very very significant
technology offer which does include
enhanced surveillance it does include
ampr on the roads coming up to the
beaches we've also offered to put more
officers
unwarranted because they will not take
warranted officers but these are the
things that i will be working through
very specifically now because the status
quo cannot persist and i think you know
there's a full understanding of this on
the french side and as i've so as i'd
say to the house the one thing we
absolutely are as a government we are
incredibly propositional
to
france in particular we have to find
joint solutions and if it means actually
doing more with france and persuading
them to take on more support we will
absolutely strain everything you to do
so
in greenwood thank you madam deputy
speaker and our hearts go out to all
those affected by yesterday's terrible
tragedy but there was already deep
concern in my constituency about the
government's approach to protecting men
women and children seeking refuge in the
uk and i also have many constituents
with family members in fear of their
lives and seeking to escape afghanistan
following the taliban takeover a new
resettlement pathway for vulnerable
afghans was announced in august but
three months later we still don't know
when the afghan citizens resettlement
scheme will be operational or how those
who are outside the uk will be able to
access it so please can the home
secretary tell us today well normal lady
makes very important points about the
afghan
resettlement scheme and it was announced
in august at a time of great crisis
obviously without pitting actually
taking place at the time
my honourable friend the minister for
the afghan resettlement scheme will be
updating colleagues in due course on
this i would have a madame deputy
speaker like to just emphasize to
colliso with operation pitting with alt
pitton we we evacuated 15 000 people we
are still in the process of trying to
resettle them and in terms of resettling
more people for afghanistan and i know
the cases are coming through and across
government it's fcdo and mod with the
arab cases there are cases that are
being followed through with the mod
we are trying to make sure that we can
again bring people forward when we bring
people forward that we can get them
settled rather than what we have seen
sadly and we're very very upfront about
this as well being put into hotels in
adequate accommodation and we need them
in the community
sir edward lee
what's an appalling and entirely
foreseeable
tragedy
will the home secretary agree with me
that we cannot wait on her excellent
bill we cannot wait on the french
cooperating with us and taking these
poor people back as they should we have
to act now in a national emergence to
save lives there are only two countries
in the world who have solved this
problem
australia
which has an offshore processing center
and greece that does push back we have
to be tough
we have to face down the human rights
lawyers if governments are weak people
die
deputy speaker well just in response to
my writing friends colleagues
i echo his frustration fully now in
terms of toughness i've been very clear
and i know this does upset some right
humble nonverbal members in this house i
have not ruled anything out and i put
every option on the table not just with
france by the way but with other
counterparts
greece in terms of pushbacks they
actually have special forces they use
their military they use a hellenic coast
guard and they use frontex as well just
for the record for this house as i said
i've seen that they also have a program
of reception centers which my right of a
friend will know and is aware of that is
part of the plan for the new plan for
immigration as well in terms of how we
have differentiation how we deal with
the reform of the asylum system and case
work progressing as well the fact of the
matter is there is no one silver bullet
solution to this and i know he
understands this and i know my
colleagues do as well that is why the
new plan for immigration is important
and the nationalism borders bill um all
colleagues will hear shortly in terms of
the bill coming back to report stage in
this house and the next stages with that
bill that bill is an important piece of
legislation madam deputy speaker because
it will set the direction of travel and
importantly it will give the government
more powers to actually be much much
firmer and it'll end many of the pull
factors that have existed for too long
and actually have helped to facilitate
and encourage illegal migration
jeremy corbyn thank you madam deputy
speaker does the home secretary accept
that the
only way in which people traffickers and
gangs can operate is because of the
absolute desperation of people across
europe and indeed across the world and
instead of concentrating on more
frontiers more barbed wire more
surveillance and so on not just in this
country but all across europe what we
should be doing is looking at the causes
of asylum in the first place the
environmental disasters the wars the
abuse of human rights the poverty and
what are we doing to ensure that the
european convention and the un
conventions are actually adhered to an
upheld those asylum seekers are
desperate people trying to survive in
this world pushing them back is not a
solution it is brutality that will go
down in history as a brutal treatment of
desperate people at a desperate time
secretary i thank the right honourable
gentleman for his comments and first and
foremost there is a great deal of work
and i just should emphasize this as well
i mean his comments are really sort of
put in as
presented in a light that actually is
quite unfair and unreflective of the
work that takes place across government
in terms of multilateral organizations
the global situations humanitarian
crises lead to displacement climate
crisis leader displacement that is a
fact of life none of this is new and
it's existed for decades and decades and
that is why the international community
does come together whether it's
inconvenient power through the european
union through the un multilateral system
that is exactly how it works but the
reality is as well madam deputy speaker
speaker it is not the case that everyone
that has come to this country illegally
whether it's in the back of lorries or
small boats historically are asylum
seekers um well when they have their
legal their rights exhausted and then we
try to remove them there are many many
barriers to removal and that is
effectively what the nationality borders
bill will address and i appreciate the
honourable gentleman in the corner
doesn't doesn't want to um support the
bill but at the same time migrants
are not just in the hands of people
smugglers they are traveling through
safe countries where there are
functioning asylum seekers in these safe
countries where they could claim asylum
and of course that also is something
that all international partners should
be supporting and working to achieve
dr julian lewis thank you madam deputy
speaker didn't the honorable lady
opposite put her finger on the problem
when she referred to afghanistan where
there are many legitimate asylum seekers
who deserve to come here
and isn't the problem that if you have
the fairest asylum seeking system in the
world a queue will form
and there will always be some people who
are not prepared to queue but want to
jump to the head of the queue
and therefore isn't the only way to
deter that to show
not that they won't get across the
channel not that getting across the
channel is terribly dangerous but that
if they do get across the channel and
they have jumped the queue they will be
returned to another country how can she
secure that yeah
well madam secretary speaker i think
i've spoken in this house a few times
now about returns agreements and the
difficulties around getting bilateral
returns
i state again for the record that i have
put on the offer on the table another
offer to my french counterpart minister
darwin today that we will discuss i'm
very happy to discuss returns agreements
with him
in the usual sense but also to look at
family reunions um and children
unaccompanied asylum seeking children as
well we don't want kids we do not want
to see children and family members be in
the hands of traffickers and having
these established routes and working
with our partners to establish returns
agreements is absolutely the right thing
to do i have stated many times before
with eu with regards to eu countries
this is a matter that sits with the
commission it is a commission competence
um there is a great deal of frustration
amongst the eu member states on this
issue which is why i will continue and
am continuing to pursue my um
discussions with the commission for home
the commissioner of home affairs
patrick grady
speaker i hope she can confirm that
there's no such thing as an illegal
asylum seeker seeking asylum is a human
right and when she says
that people should seek asylum in the
first safe country that they come to she
can confirm that that's an aspect of the
government's hostile environment policy
and not a legal or treaty requirement in
any international obligation and on top
of all of that at what point can the uk
ever be the first safe country given
that this island is surrounded by water
what are the routes by which the united
kingdom could be the first safe country
in which a displaced asylum seeker
arrives here normal gentleman actually
misses a fundamental point a about the
asylum system and the whole issue about
people who come to the country who are
not actually genuine asylum seekers who
masquerade in this asylum system we do
know actually we do know and there are
many many cases there are many cases and
i think also madam jbc because there has
to be a recognition this actually shows
how detached the honourable gentleman is
from the real world we cannot have a
policy where we can accommodate everyone
and to play back a bit of eu rhetoric
and language back to him the concept of
burden share which is why we actually do
seek to work with our counterparts and
we do cooperate with other countries and
we do continue to work in a constructive
manner around returns agreement we do
also seek to change our law so that
individuals are not constantly using the
appeals process and uk the uk legal aid
system as well to frustrate the ability
of the government to remove people from
our country who have no legal basis to
stay in our country
i really do think the honorable
gentleman really misses the point and in
particular at a time when we know that
there is a major global migration crisis
we have to find collective solutions to
this problem and not just take the
ideological approach that the gentleman
is taking
florida social army thank you madam
destiny speaker um so yesterday was a
very
sad day and i think all of us would have
been moved
seeing those reports and for me
as i put my children to bed yesterday i
just thought about the conditions that
that poor child went through
and we cannot allow this situation
to be exploited by those pushing
anti-immigration agenda
and i welcome the home secretary saying
that she will look at all options and
that she's having those discussions in
terms of operational and diplomatic and
to bring down those people smugglers and
i welcome her comment in that looking at
safe routes but will she please
look at maybe another option in terms of
providing
an um humanitarian visa scheme so that
people don't have to get on these boats
they are seeking safety and refuge for
their families that's another option
that the home secretary could look at
well madam deputy speaker there are also
lots of options that we could all look
at but we need the legal frameworks to
do some of this as well that is why i'm
bringing forward the nationality in
borders bill
the
tragedy in the channel draws into sharp
focus an issue about which we have no
doubt
of the of the set of the home
secretaries determined intentions
illustrated by baltimore which will go
some way to fixing a broken asylum
system gained by traffickers by economic
migrants and by rights lawyers but she
needs to go further
and that's why the common sense group of
mps have written her saying we need to
disrupt those criminal gangs we need
offshore processing of claims and we
just turn around votes in the channel as
the law allows us to do
for people who voted to take back
control have every right to ask the
question if you can't protect the
integrity of the borders what can you
control
i thank my writing friend for his
comments and he will know that within
the bill as well he mentions offshoring
third country these are all options that
are under consideration and the bill
does actually new plan for immigration
covers those areas he's absolutely right
in terms of the principal point that he
made which is why we are determined and
we will not just stop and cease with the
measures that we've already announced
we'll look to augment and enhance some
of the measures as well because the
state of crisis that i think we're
seeing with global migration issues
right now
and the appalling loss of life and
deaths that we have seen it's incumbent
upon everyone governments and law
enforcement border controls all the
various agencies to come together to
stop this awful trade in human
trafficking andrew mitchell
thank you madam deputy speaker and may i
thank the home secretary for the content
and the tone with which she has
delivered her
statement today does she agree with me
that dealing with these criminal gangs
of people smugglers we are dealing with
in every sense the modern day equivalent
of the slave traders of your and will
she ensure that the full the full force
and diligence of the intelligence
services and the security services
working with their counterparts in
friendly states are brought together to
address this terrible challenge and to
prevent
further such tragedies as we saw
yesterday can my right honourable friend
see any reason to object to processing
asylum claims at all british embassies
so those who have a successful claim
which are the significant majority of
those arriving by boat can come here in
a legal and humane way once asylum has
been granted rather than risking their
lives just for the chance to file
paperwork in the first place
my second friend made some very very
important and valid points and first and
foremost he will absolutely know and i
do agree with him we are seeing what is
now modern day slave trade there is no
question about that
which is why madam deputy speaker the
full force as my writing friend says of
our intelligence security law
enforcement partners and agencies not
just in the uk or in france but upstream
and my right and friendly very very
familiar with the footprint that
government has particularly in other
countries upstream and places like
africa for example as well where there's
a great deal of work that takes place to
stop smuggling of people um and the
human trafficking that has taken place
and in terms of processing outside of
the united kingdom this is very much
part of the process that we are looking
at now in terms of safe and legal routes
but also creating the right kind of
parameters and working with many of the
humanitarian aid agencies that my
rational friend will be familiar with
who have led much of the safe and legal
routes and resettlement schemes around
the world
brandon o'hara
speaker may i add my voice to those
sending their condolences to the
families and loved ones of those who
died in this unspeakable tragedy but
last night i tuned into the bbc 10
o'clock news to get the latest on this
terrible disaster and i was absolutely
appalled when a presenter informed me
that around 30 migrants had drowned
madam deputy speaker migrants don't
drown
people drown
men women and children drown so the
secretary of state join me in asking the
bbc news editorial team and any other
news outlet thinking of using that term
to reflect on the use of such
dehumanizing language and afford these
poor people the respect that they
deserve
in terms of language that is used and we
see we see a lot we hear a lot and even
during the afghanistan
operations are not put in i heard a lot
of language that quite frankly seem to
be inappropriate around people who are
fleeing so yes i will
steve baker
deputy speaker i think people in wycombe
would expect the government to act with
absolute resolve to get a grip of this
problem but also compassion to save life
and look after people can she reassure
me that that is her policy to look after
people that get a grip of this problem
well i absolutely reassure my honorable
friend on not just
it's more than grip i think in terms of
the approach that we are taking um the
use of the word grip you know we've just
been speaking about language is quite a
simplistic term actually when we think
about the complexity of this issue this
is a very very complicated issue um and
it requires action around or across a
whole plethora a plethora of areas
but humanity and decency is absolutely
crucial
and without labeling the point madam
deputy speaker this does come back to
how people are treated when they come to
our country how we accommodate them and
how we support them and this is what we
want to change with the national anthem
borders bill because we can do things
better our system is broken and it's
incumbent that we actually apply a whole
range of skills experience and knowledge
to actually provide a better system
chiomora thank you madam deputy speaker
and it is truly heartbreaking to think
of the
lives the hopes the talents extinguished
by the sea in their journey to our
shores the journey of the home secretary
characterizes as unnecessary but i could
i gently say to her that the when men
women and children getting into the boat
clearly didn't think so and we see more
boats arriving today so will the home
secretary acknowledge that her policies
are not working and that vulnerable
people are paying the price and that
what we need is safe secure and fair
routes into this country and she has
failed to put them in place i'm deputy
speaker in response to the honourable
lady that is exactly what the
nationalism borders bill does
robert jones
i support my right or friend in pursuing
all long-term options including offshore
processing which i think will play an
important part but would she agree with
me that in the short term we will see
more tragedies like this unless we can
agree a strategy with the french and it
is within the gift of the president of
france to bring this to an end
now
that will require more action by then
but it must be in our mutual interests
because the more people who cross the
channel the more people will come to
france
absolutely right and hence the
discussion that took place between the
prime minister and president macron last
night
we have we have been absolutely
assiduous and forthright in making these
points to our counterparts in france
over the last two years and the offers
madame deputy speaking you've heard the
offers that we put forward to president
macron the interior minister the whole
machinery of the french government we
absolutely encourage them and urge them
to take these offers forward they may
not be perfect but that's that's not the
point we need to deploy every single
tool that we have to save lives and to
prevent the loss of life and that's
effectively what this is now about
rachel master
thank you madam deputy speaker this is
absolutely tragic 27 people including
children and a pregnant woman
desperate for a safe future
were killed while being exploited
it's nothing short of murder
the foreign secretary the foreign
affairs select committee two years ago
concluded that closing down safe routes
drives people into the hands of people
smugglers
so will she immediately withdraw her
dangerous nationality and borders bill
which does just that
and personally safe routes of passage to
avoid more tragedies
deputy speaker is no and that's
effectively the nationality of borders
bill does create safe and legal routes
so christopher cho madam deputy speaker
my right honourable friend said in the
at the end of her statement that
crossing the channel in a small boat is
illegal
wood that it was but it isn't illegal as
that was confirmed by the crown
prosecution service on the 8th of july
what would make it illegal would be
passing into law my illegal immigration
offences bill which is due for second
reading tomorrow and i should be
grateful if my right uncle friend could
agree to meet me to discuss the contents
of that bill and how that will
contribute to what we all want to see
which is an end to this vile trade yeah
yeah i think there is absolutely more
that needs to be done so ministers will
be happy to meet the right on beyond
alan cairns
thank you madam deputy speaker on monday
i shared my concern to the
home secretary that the french
authorities potentially turning a blind
eye to some of the activities going on
in the on the northern coast of france
we're putting some of the most
vulnerable people at risk
sadly that tragedy emerged yesterday and
it's encouraging to see that five people
were arrested overnight but those five
people were active yesterday last week
last month and probably last year now i
recognize the diplomacy that's required
but can i urge my right honourable
friend to use every effort to bring the
newfound urgency together to work across
government across authority to ensure
that all action all possible action is
taken to combat the actions of these
people smugglers
multiple friendships question he's of
course absolutely right there is um
arrests have been made and it's not for
me to comment in detail in terms of
the type of arrest and the type of work
that's taking place but let me assure my
writing friend in the house
certainly for the last two years the
level of intelligence sharing
both in the uk
and in and in mainland in france and
further than france as well because we
do go much both in france and
intelligence sharing has been absolutely
pivotal to arrests and convictions and
smashing up gangs
there has been a lot of outstanding and
good work that has taken place and i
think if i remember right on monday i
might have alluded to a really big case
last week where an albanian criminal um
was prosecuted so there is a lot of work
that takes place um i have to say these
these outcomes are always reported as
well they're not always reported
but collectively there have been some
very very significant arrests and
prosecutions
dj brock thank you madame deputy speaker
and i believe kosler has written to the
home secretary seeking an urgent meeting
regarding her recent attacks on scottish
councils
and their responsibilities to asylum
seekers and i would urge you to take up
that offer so she can have a few home
truths uh about the situation relayed to
her but does she agree that now is also
the time in the face of this absolutely
appalling tragedy to stop talking about
this as simply being a french or a uk
issue and instead address it as an
international or global issue if you
like and that it is vital that disputes
over northern ireland and fishing
are treated entirely separately from
working together to find a joint
solution madam deputy speaker um i take
issue with the comments from the
honourable lady first of all for her
information the immigration minister met
with kozler on monday and these issues
were not raised and did not come up
secondly when it comes to um the actual
issue of migration um i've never said
that it's a uk france issue at all i've
always said it's a global issue there's
no point pointing to my colleagues you
were pushing your question the
honourable lady was put in the question
directly to me um i've always said i
have always said and maintained that it
is a global crisis and actually i've
always been proactive in speaking to my
counterparts across eu member states um
and other countries and even i've even
hosted meetings with them as well so i
think having that context is equally as
important
diane johnson
deputy speaker this is the most awful
tragedy and i would like to add my
condolences to all those who have been
affected
but it's right to say isn't it that the
home office has failed to get a grip of
this issue for far too long
and in a week when the home affairs
select committee has recommended that
the windrush compensation scheme should
be removed from the home office because
of issues of competency
isn't it now time that this matter
should also be removed from the home
office given to the cabinet office and
there should be a cross-government
response
for the benefit of the house madam
deputies because there is a
cross-government response to this
thank you madam deputy speaker whilst we
don't know the details or nationalities
of those that sadly lost their lives in
the channel
yesterday
we do know that very large numbers of
people who are refugees from the
oppressive brutal regime in iran are
desperately seeking to cross the channel
to come to this country
can she look at
the example that has been set by the
albanian governments who've said who
moved satisfactorily camp liberty from
iran into camparaf and is as a model of
how to treat people who are refugees in
the closest country possible to the
iranian border that is somehow we can
set up these sort of camps and
opportunities for people fleeing from
those regimes rather than them being
forced to take this perilous journey
my humble friend makes
what is madame deputy speaker i think a
highly highly relevant and important
point and at times of crisis of global
migration crisis and if we think back
actually not that long ago to 2014-15
um our policy and approach and
internationally supported as well was to
keep people within the region and i am
referring madam deputy speaker to the
syrian crisis well we worked with
counterparts and we are still working
with counterparts and colleagues in
jordan and neighbouring countries in the
region there was a great deal of work
that took place
but the sadness of all of this is it
took a migration crisis and tragedies of
the loss of life for the international
community to convene and coalesce and
come together in that way
all i can say right now is that the
british government and i are working
night and day to bring partners together
to recognize that no one country can
solve this on their own and that is why
we need stronger cooperation across the
board now so that we can address these
um issues
together
rosie darfield
deputy speaker the people of east kent
are horrified and deeply upset by what
the chief rabbi this morning called an
unspeakable tragedy happening on our
shores
we should be ashamed too that amongst
the dead was a soldier who served
alongside british armed forces personnel
and reportedly felt unable to wait any
longer for help to come not an illegal
migrant i think the home secretary would
agree
will the government please act not
simply to repel those human beings
desperate enough to risk this incredibly
dangerous crossing but to immediately
open the afghan citizens resettlement
scheme and safe family reunion utes to
prevent roots to prevent more deaths
like this
i'm deputy speaker the honourable lady
to my comments earlier on both of those
points
julie mason thank you madam deputy
speaker and we've seen consistently uh
with afghanistan and hong kong that the
british people
react with incredible generosity of
spirit to people who are fleeing uh
persecution oppression and conflict
does my um honorable right honourable
friend agree
that the safe and legal routes that
she's referred to consistently and which
are central and integral to the
nationality and borders bill are vital
but they also have to be the only viable
route into the uk
to preserve life of course but also to
retain the uh support of the british
public and the integrity of our asylum
system which is what we all want to see
absolutely right and spot on madame
deputy speaker so the changes that the
government have brought in we are very
clear about legal rules and also the
issues and we're very open and honest
for 20 years the asylum system has just
remained in aspect it has not been
touched it has not been reformed and it
needs reforming and with that of course
we have set up resettlement rules hong
kong those bnos look at the way that
scheme has worked it has been phenomenal
and it's incredibly moving to see how
people have been resettled across the
united kingdom as well with afghanistan
and there are many other schemes as well
syrian refugees that have come over too
we need to build upon those successes
and do the right thing for people that
are fleeing persecution because it is
that bond of trust
with the british public as well the
british public are warm and generous and
we need to deliver for them but we
cannot be walked out all over by other
countries that are not stepping up
taking their responsibilities and which
is why we have to continue with this
cooperation that we have with all our
neighbors
jim michelle thank you madam deputy
speaker can i thank the secretary of
state for her commitment to finding a
solution for this and it's very clear
that the nobility is doing just that uh
my heart aches
at the lost lives that have been now
become a reality sadly today on behalf
of my part of the dup uh i convey my
sincere sympathies to all those who
grieve for their loved ones who have
lost over the last time
would the minister consider utilizing
private patrol companies offering
services with boats ready and equipped
to help the patrol of the sea such as
one who has contacted and emailed me to
highlight a dairy facility called
thesaurus marine solutions is there a
rule sector state for private enterprise
and helping the fight against these
dangerous crossings thank you
thank you madam deputy the answer is yes
there is a role and the home office has
been tasked to look at private sector
companies and support and in fact even
with my french counterpart this morning
i've once again not for the first time
put that offer on the table as well to
have other contractors to join the
collective efforts
hollaman it's the background of british
troops being sent to poland to help
secure the border with
belarus can the home secretary confirm
and clarify the basis of her broad and
generous offer to the french has she
offered border force cutters to work
close to shore off the french close in
conjunction with the french and has she
offered the deployment of british troops
and uk police if necessary under french
command to operate on french beaches
yes madam deputy speaker i have
david simmons
thank you madam deputy speaker may i
first commend the home secretary on her
very robust response to the snp
the londoner of hellington is currently
buckling under the strain of looking
after around 10 of the refugees in the
whole country including large numbers
bust up from dover and almost none of
those people have a route to scotland
but they asked my general friend
that recognizing the importance of safe
and legal routes
and the comments made by the french
foreign minister about some of the pull
factors in the uk
will she consider what steps could be
brought forward to remove a grant of
asylum from those whose claim is
subsequently shown to have been bogus
madam deputy speaker thank you first of
all i would just like to put on the
record actually my thanks to the london
borough of hillingdon
and also to many other local authorities
madam deputy speaker across the country
but they are predominantly in london
london is feeling the pressure in terms
of accommodation hotels and housing
and he is right of course in terms of um
his own suggestion in terms of moving
moving forward um on solutions but
actually working together and you know
we this is exactly why we are looking to
reform the system through the
nationalism borders bill we have to have
that differentiation
richard holden thank you very much
indeed madame dr speaker the lives are
tragically being lost in the channel and
the british people want these gangs
smashed the crossing stopped and people
processed in the nearest country the
opposition have voted again and again
against our measures and nationality and
borders bill to cut down on human
trafficking via small boats and the
shadow home secretary has called our
proposals unconscionable in my local
area the local labour party and the lib
dems none of whom i see here today are
even campaigning against an immigration
removal center for foreign criminals and
failed asylum seekers does the home
secretary agree with me the labour's
failure to support the necessary
legislation shows that when the trips
are down that they not only don't
understand the views of the british
people but tragically are failing to
protect those being exploited by
criminal gangs whose callous and
criminal behavior means people are left
to die in the channel
my honorable friend act makes some very
very important points here and obviously
in terms of removal center we have
removal centers for very very good and
strong reasons madam deputy speaker
these are people with no legal rights to
remain in our country and there are
reasons as to why we have to put them in
removal centers to you know with the
processes that we have to get to move
them on but the fundamental point here
is of course the reforms that we are
trying to bring in which are being
thoughted by the party opposite and
actually by stopping these changes and
reforms they're only playing into the
hands of the people smugglers and those
quite frankly who are being put in the
hands of the traffickers
and finally the prize for patience and
perseverance
goes to duncan baker
that will teach me for being last in as
well um could i say the situation
yesterday was an absolute tragedy but
it's absolutely clear what the home
secretary has said in her words there is
no single silver bullet to fix this
problem would you agree with me that
broadly there are around three huge
areas to cover number one international
cooperation has got to be there to work
together with other countries the
domestic legislation has to be put in
place which is what we are doing through
the nationality and borders bill to fix
our borders and to fix the broken
silence system and lastly we need the
toughest
possible measures to crack down on the
surveillance and the criminality of
those gangs who are quite frankly just
aiding and abetting the situation every
day
he's absolutely right and i thank him
for his comments because he's summed up
the totality of the challenge that
confronts us all has existed for a long
period of time and that's exactly why
we're attempting to fix the broken
system by tackling these issues the
gangs at source going upstream using
intelligence fixing the system here in
the united kingdom and of course our
continued work with our counterparts
around the world
thank you
point of order dr alan whitehead
thank you madam deputy speaker yesterday
in the urgent question on bowel going
into special administration
the business secretary told my
honourable friend the member for rwanda
after refusing to answer a question from
my right honourable friend the shadow
business secretary that and i quote
there is no government bailout
yet we learned from a court hearing on
the same day
indeed on the front page of the
telegraph and other papers today that
the taxpayer
is on the hook for as much as 1.7
billion pounds as a result of this
government's failure to properly
regulate the energy market
i ask your guidance madam deputy speaker
is it right and proper for a government
minister to say one thing to this house
and another thing to the courts
and also madam deputy speaker whether
you have any guidance
about how the business secretary can be
brought back to this house to explain
why he has misled it in his answers to
the uq of yesterday
order
order although i'm not listening to
sedentary comments i don't need to be
reminded
i hope that the honorable gentleman will
come back to the dispatch box and find
other words for his last sentence i'm
quite sure that no right honourable
member of this house could have misled
it
i
thank the deputy
speaker for her
guidance on this matter and of course i
withdraw the question of misleading the
house i hope the
business secretary will come to the
house to explain his comments
uh in the due course of time
thank the honourable gentleman that is
the perfectly polite and in order
question however
uh it is uh not a point of order for the
chair as i i think the honourable
gentleman knows
ministers are of course responsible
for the content of their speeches and
answers at the dispatch box and the
chair has no control over such matters
if however
the honorable gentleman
wishes to take the matter further and to
require the secretary of state in
question to come back to the house and
revisit the matter on which he is in
disagreement
with the said minister
then i suggest that he visits the the
clerks in the table office who will give
him some advice on how he might go about
that and i'm also sure that the treasury
bench will have heard
and i have a sent from the minister who
is now at the dispatch box the treasury
bench have heard of what the honourable
gentleman has said and i trust that his
concerns
will be
uh
will be brought to the attention
of the appropriate secretary of state
and
that the matter will be revisited and if
necessary
clarified
i trust that satisfies the honourable
debt
thank
you we now come
to the back bench debate